we welcome you back to CBS mornings
we've got new details about a story that
could have a big impact on U.S air
travel CBS News has learned that justice
department lawyers could file a lawsuit
as soon as today to block JetBlue's
proposed merger with Spirit Airlines
back in October shareholders of the
low-cost carrier voted to accept
JetBlue's 3.8 billion dollar buyout the
combined Airline would become the fifth
largest in the nation we've also got
another big announcement this one from
JetBlue on the flights first on CBS
morning this is very exciting for you
who like to go overseas tickets are
officially on sale today for the
airline's new direct route to Paris from
New York's JFK Airport that starts June
29th joining us now is JetBlue CEO Robin
Hayes Ms Trey is always good to have you
at the table great to be here thanks for
having me shall we start with a lawsuit
or shall we start with the prices it's a
pleasure sir I'll let you pick I'll let
you pick well let's start with a lawsuit
so how are you feeling about that you
know the justice department is saying
nope not so far fast you're merging with
with spirit
yeah I mean um clearly we're
disappointed but we're not surprised I
mean we said when we
um um got the offer approved by the
spirit shareholders last year that we
didn't think we would close to the first
half of 2024 you know expecting a a
trial I mean the issue in the U.S
industry and this is where we agree
actually with the Department of Justice
is that we've got four large Airlines
with about 20 percent of the market each
that's 80 the rest of us have 20 between
us and so what we're trying to do is
make a bigger JetBlue to bring the
JetBlue brand the JetBlue product the
JetBlue people and the JetBlue fares
more nationally than we can do today
this is not Pepsi buying Coke together
we're going to be eight to nine percent
of the market you know you said a fifth
fifth largest airline a distant fifth
largest airline so look we but they're
saying it won't give uh customers
passengers options when it comes to
low-cost flying because now you you will
essentially own that market well let
let's see what the you know let's see
what the lawsuit says I mean the overlap
between JetBlue and Spoon is really low
certainly uh in my opinion much lower
than we've seen in previous mergers by
the way which the government have have
approved and um you know um just so much
more benefit the ability to add new
markets the ability to flight a new
destinations that neither JetBlue or
Spirit do today individually so people
are very price sensitive A lot of people
flying on your airline are using their
own dollar right it's not a corporate
card it's not a business expense are you
telling people they should root for this
merger because prices will go down on
tickets oh absolutely I mean a JetBlue I
mean I think the difference between
JetBlue and other airlines is we don't
believe you have to choose between a low
fare and and great service and if you
look out of New York where we started
every time JetBlue flies on a market
fares go down in that market it's
actually called the JetBlue effect
um because we because of our product and
because we appeal to all sorts of
customers Legacy Airlines which fly the
most capacity they will match they're
fat they will bring down their fares to
match JetBlue so everyone benefits look
JetBlue and spirit together will be
eight or nine percent most people are
still going to be flying on the other
airlines that's where you're going to
save the really big dollars by having a
a big a big uh bigger JetBlue I flew
JetBlue this weekend uh to Palm Beach
and I'm not just saying this because
you're here but the JetBlue crews are
different I don't know if you train them
differently the pilot came out and said
hello to everybody in the plane the
flight attendants write down their names
and I find them very engaging we don't
need to discuss that any further than
say good job
but but it does feel unsafe these days
Robin to fly I mean it seems like
there's many incidents that are
happening I don't know if it's happening
more and we're noticing or that there's
something wrong I just feel when I get
on a plane it's very very frightening to
me regardless of the airline well we
don't want certainly don't want you to
feel fight and go I mean the the US
airline industry is incredibly safe I
know
is handling about 45 000 flights a day
millions and millions of flights a year
and you know there are a few uh
incidents serious incidents that have
occurred uh recently JetBlue just had a
very close call yeah so we had a a
situation in Boston where um we had an
airplane that was coming into land and a
private airplane took the one way even
though they had been told to wait yeah
now our Pilots are trained what our
Pilots are trained to do is that to as
they come into land if the runway is not
clear you do what's called a go around
yes uh and that is something that we
train
um I've been flying on airplanes for 33
years I've probably been involved in
tours
scary absolutely it is it is you know it
is it is um you know it is something
that is disconcerting if you're on the
airplane I have I have been on airplanes
that have done that
um but it's it's not unsafe and I think
you know what's really
um what I'm really proud of in the US is
how the FAA the airlines everyone worked
together to keep the system safe so it's
working you don't think anything needs
to change in order to improve safety we
every time an incident like this happens
there's an investigation and a review
and the system
changes because of it you know there are
new procedures that we introduce and
it's like this kind of constant feedback
loop of things happen and then people
get trained to address it so look I'm
flying all the time and I feel as safe
today as I ever did Robin let me ask you
about inflation uh the CPI index last
month had inflation at 6.4 overall over
last year but airfares are up 25 over 25
how do you address that well I think you
know what you've seen
um I think there were two issues in the
airline industry first of all our fuel
costs are up significantly and it's not
just the cost of the fuel but the what
we call the crack spread which is the
price to take the raw material and then
turn it into a refined product that you
can put in the airplane those costs are
up significantly in addition you know
the industry is still hasn't bought as
much capacity back as there is demand
you know there are delays on on new
aircraft deliveries there's been
challenges ramping up Staffing as as
other Industries have seen and so you
know I think 20 as we move to 23 24 as
things start to catch up you'll see some
of that
um uh normalized but there's still
plenty of great deals out there like
Paris as well
before we get because I want to end on
Paris I think we should end on some good
news but Wall Street Journal poll says
JetBlue finished in last place overall
for the second year in a row for worst
Airline
that can't be good for you to hear no no
one wants to be lost right um you know
that that pole uh girl is really a
function of on-time performance and I
think
um one of the challenges that says on
time mishandled baggage uh involuntary
bumping you think it's mostly about on
time well a lot yeah so um mishandle
baggage
um is a number of measures including on
time but you know I think where where we
have traditionally not done as well as
others is in the era of on Time
Performance and that really relates to
the geography that we're in I mean you
know that New York and the Northeast has
by Far and Away the most Air Traffic
Control delays the most weather impact
of any part of the country and a proof
point is in January so we just had
actually a pretty good January the
weather in the Northeast was good and
the airline that canceled the lowest
percentage of flights of any airline in
the country so that's good news let's
talk about Paris
what's the price point give it to us
well we're excited you know know I mean
talk about the JetBlue effect talk about
low fares so we're announcing today that
we're going to start flying to Paris on
the 29th of uh June and the round trip
Fair uh is 479
um that is Leslie off wow wow and uh you
know uh in uh in mint which is our
premium experience it's uh under two
thousand dollars 18.99 because I'm going
to go quickly uh Tony you're going to
Paris this is by the way well I'm going
early I'm going on in April we've been
doing this on London now for a couple of
years if you look at business class
first to London yeah I think they're
about half of what I don't know when
Beyonce's performing in Paris but that
would be something that people should
look at yeah yeah and you know if you
blew it on Valentine's Day this is the
this is a pickup move right now log on
get that uh sub 500 price Rancho Robin
Hayes thank you very much thank you